you guys are adored adored by women
everywhere not just women but wouldn't
go crazy for you they'd go nuts for you
who was better with the ladies growing
up oh my god I suck not drew drew it was
like watching a Ben Stiller character it
was so awkward when we were younger
so Drew's the robot that was his
nickname when we were growing up because
he had no emotions that he was aware of
efficient and so he was terrible with
girls couldn't talk to him so he read a
book about challenging himself to talk
to girls and so he made there's a book
on how to talk to girls early but I
challenge myself so today I will talk to
one girl tomorrow I will talk to two
next day I'll ask one out and I got it
work he eventually then the pendulum
swung the other way and he became a
total douche and he was like so the book
was called how to be a douche might bite
your applause you can rate the douchery
of this we're set they sing at a bar so
we're I didn't at the time I don't know
we were like maybe 19 something like
that in Canada you can go to the bar at
19 and so we're at the bar and there's
this girl who's cute across the bar and
Drew's like watch this he's sitting
there he's like hey I saw you staring so
we're gonna do this and it worked on a
date for the record I never said are we
gonna do this we did do that no but
honestly as much as I read the book and
got good at the end of the day doesn't
really matter because I'm still a dork
and I don't really have moves I don't
hit other you know I just I do awkward
things and it works for my wife that's
how I hooked her in my line with her was
where'd you get that water rest him now
he's useless again now that's how a line
you used on your wife when you met her
was vertibirds yet that water so she was
we were at this fashion event and
Jonathan on were these celebrity models
and anyway we were at the back backstage
and I saw her she was holding a bottle
of water it's telling me the whole time
about how all this girl she's beautiful
look this is amazing and then this was
holding I was holding pizza she was
alone water my my big line to her was
where'd you get that water and her
response was
where'd you get that pizza and yet again
here we are two years yeah I don't that
is a I'll teach you I think know it I'm
gonna say something I'm gonna suggest
that it helps to be good-looking because
I'm gonna suggest because in my life
throughout my entire life when I've
asked women where did you get that water
they say over there go over there and
get the water and when I come back
they're gone that's that's not a line
that works but my thing is when you say
it to them are you doing some like
creepy eyebrow thing like where did you
get that of water you shouldn't be let
go do that when you're doing no I'm not
doing anything creepy I'm just merely
saying where did you get that water
anyone ever hit on you while you were
filming an episode Oh God he gets it
more than I do the rugged country I was
single for a long time and it didn't
even matter if they were single we had
this one homeowner
not to be named she would hit on me so
bad with her husband right there and he
was oblivious to what was going on I'm
gonna show you I need a doorway I'm
gonna go over the doorway here I would
be working and he's would whisper things
at me like I'm not hitting on you we
don't know where she is we're looking
for her everywhere and then all of a
sudden music comes on and this is all we
see she'd be in the deep background of
the world it comes on and she locks eyes
with Jonathan and she would do this like
weird couldn't ball see I kinetic creepy
in front of her husband and so what we
actually did so you got to realize we
shoot a lot of shows we've worked with
400 families on our shows now are we
just hit our 400th episode and we have
helped a lot of people you get a kitchen
you get a kitchen so with all of that
there's definitely probably a dozen
homeowners who have been so bad so
creepy so weird and we made a montage
just for internally for us to view of
some of the worst moments and that one
was in there them are amazing in their
thankful and their every now and then
they're just a few that's one a piece of
Jonathan right they want Jonathan to put
a little hardwood in the bedroom all
right
it won't set us up oh yeah so I don't
know Chum you buy a hardwood in the
bedroom
sorry soft oh yeah there you go now
you're talking my language little right
yes you think about it though most
construction terms are derived from a
pervert somewhere because there's your
hardwood there's your [ __ ] you got to
put [ __ ] everywhere there's all wait a
minute who said you have to put [ __ ]
have you never handled cow got it god
I'm going yeah all these things like you
know everything in construction if you
think go Google all the terms for
construction they're derived from the
weirdest most perverted things I don't
know why I think Jonathan's book yeah
yeah true so if you found that to be
true indeed you're a handy guy well
there's like weird like there's plumbing
parts that called a nipple like and that
was like you know aren't like the way
things are male and female for screwed
weird because you have two nipples yeah
I don't know I just think it's we
couldn't you call it like I don't know
that's what everyone says the industry
but when you see these like big burly
construction trades and they're over
there the like yeah you got to lube up
the nipples now let's go over there and
lay some [ __ ] you can't help but turn
into like it I talk like that all the
time and I do I do not do any
construction around the house we're
gonna lube up the nipples and wipers
wipe around the [ __ ] all right let's go
man I don't know if aging HDTV oh by
that that's after garden no miss Joe
won't air